the Dancing with the Stars pros for
season 27 are officially here no Max and
Peter but ABC announced that passpo
champs Cheryl Lindsay and Whitney are
back plus fan fave Sharna Gleb Artem
Keough and Alan and then there are the
couples facing off newlyweds Emma and
Sasha and the newly engaged Jenna and
vow and speaking of Val get ready to see
him first as a judge for the ballroom
spin-off Dancing with the Stars juniors
Val telling me how the tables have
turned
how different is it to go from being in
the barn floor and being the person
being judged to now sitting on the other
side of the table it's very different
do you have an appreciation for some of
the harsh critiques you've got well I'm
excited to go into the season of Dancing
with the Stars as a contestant now to to
kind of pay my respect to the judges Val
isn't - the first pro to go from the
dance floor to the judge's table his
brother max served as a guest judge in
three different seasons julianne hough
spent five seasons handing out scores
and her brother Derek is currently a
judge on world of dance with JLo I
definitely did my research I saw the you
know other competition shows and you
know popular judges or notorious judges
like Simon Cowell I don't want to try to
be like Julianne or Derek or Simon or
anybody just want to be myself but this
two-time mirror ball champ has an added
challenge he has to critique kids sing
alongside him will be Olympic figure
skater and Dancing with the Stars winner
Adam Rippon as well as Emmy winning
choreographer Mandy Moore the show
premieres this October and his fiance
Jenna Johnson is one of the mentors you
are now judging your future wife this is
a recipe for disaster
good I am handling it I guess pretty
well I separate the two completely okay
yeah absolutely this show isn't about
Val or Jenna it's really all about the
children have we begun planning we have
begun planning yeah and by we I mean her
I want this to be the dream wedding yeah
for both of us but it's just how we
define that dream we're not part of that
dream wedding getting married at a
castle like his brother
well I think a castle is very suitable
for them I'm a little more blue collar
than that you know for me my life is a
fairy tale I mean that
[Music]